[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice
that you can use in your everyday life
hi
i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my co-host
dr greg sadler
today we're talking about truth society
and the marketplace of ideas and that's
a lot of
ideas all kind of thrown in there
together so we're getting a little
meta because we're going to have ideas
about ideas
we're also continuing what you could
call i guess a series that we didn't
realize
we were going to do as a series uh we
started out
what three episodes back yeah this is
four
so we did we did one about memory and it
was going to be memory and truth but we
mostly just talked about memory
and we did we just talked about truth a
little bit in that one didn't we
a little bit but yeah it was mostly
memory and then we did more memory and a
little bit of truth and then a lot of
truth
so there's there's a lot to these topics
they're they're not
quite as simple and straightforward as
you might think and we're trying to do a
good job as well
in not getting too abstract not getting
too academic
making sure that there's some reference
to our
ordinary life and i think in this one
perhaps there's a bit more right because
we're talking about the society that we
live in
and how we how we learn what's true
we figure out what's false um
both of them very much the application
episode
okay yeah that's that there was such a
deep
topic that it took a lot to get to the
place where we're actually
starting to apply these processes
you know this is a bit off topic but
when i
thought through a lot of the the
issues and problems and subtopics that
we're going to talk about here
i got a little dismayed you know you
think about
the society that we live in and if you
if you don't if you're not paying very
close attention
you you don't you're not as a uh
attuned to how many ways
truth is kept from us or obstacles are
set up in the way of
acquiring truth or we have people lying
to us all the time
for different reasons and you know we're
going to talk about well maybe there
should be some way for truth to like
will
you know win out or cut through or
something like that actually somebody
today on youtube one of the comments
that was interesting about one of our
previous shows
he said that in my country there's a
proverb that
lies have short legs meaning that the
truth always catches up to it right and
then if that was
true itself that would be excellent but
i think there's a lot of times where we
we find out you know the the lies
actually had long legs or much stronger
legs than than the truth so
i don't know did you have any sort of
feeling like that as you're thinking
about
some of these issues or are you pretty
still
optimistic pretty uh bullish on
on truth winning out
um no i'm i'm as you are conflicted
this is a an
issue for the times obviously and
we are are grappling with it and we will
talk about on
a couple of the topics here and how
there are different
not only like motivations but also just
different
ways at viewing things that result in
people
potentially coming to um
things that are that they perceive as
true but are not true
not because they have a negative you
know intention
to actually do that um but because they
have
been led astray uh or they come
from a certain you know antecedent
idea that would lead them away from
truth as
a good to be sought yeah and
and now this has some classical
antecedents as well you know in ancient
times
in wisdom traditions and philosophical
traditions we see this
constant refrain that the human being is
not just a rational animal but
an animal that values and desires truth
and so tries to seek it out that it's
better to you know
have truth even if the truth kind of is
is not
the best uh in in what it actually
depicts than to be lied to
or deceived and there's also you know
interesting analyses that would
in ancient philosophy for example why
are why are people
if they are naturally inclined to truth
why are they so often wrong about
certain things and
there's a lot of places you could lay
blame you know the natural
attractiveness of
objects of desire and pleasure that
overwhelm us
being children and being immature and
getting the wrong messages from adults
about
how it's so important to have social
status and it's less important to worry
about the
condition of your soul or things like
that but i think we really are
in a much more difficult
problematic situation i don't want to
say in modern times but i want to say in
late modern times
particularly with the the internet age
where
it's not as if you couldn't lie on the
you know radio or
newspapers or anything like that but it
but it's
the flow of communication is just so
pervasive now
you know the idea of having targeted ads
think about what that would have been
like
prior to the internet somebody would
have had to have like you know
worked up a dossier on you and figured
out what your deep desires are
based on some psychological
generalizations about the sort of things
you do and say and then they'd have to
like you know maybe clip out parts of
the newspaper that applied specifically
to you
shove those in your mailbox for you to
see the next day
like it feels like the only people that
could do that are like the cia
yeah or or it could be i mean you could
maybe pay people to do it if you're a
rich person
you know to find your special ads but
now we're here
but to what benefit like the cost would
at least that point in time would have
greatly outweighed the benefit of doing
that
yeah it's almost like that would be
something in an absurdist piece of
literature
right because it is kind of
inconceivable but now we
we inhabit a time and culture and space
where
targeted ads are hitting us all the time
and and for you and i who grew up you
know getting to see the internet
develop and begin to pervade our life to
the extent that
it's hard to imagine modern life without
it
it's one thing but i think for people
who are you know say eight
my college students right now they've
grown up with with that
um that is the norm for them they don't
have any
they they do have um comparison objects
you know that can allow them to think
about things being differently but it's
history or it's fiction it's not their
experience
that they can compare it to and you know
what will happen when they're having
children
you know assuming that the internet
progresses
and becomes much more personalized and
much more
what would you call it like data
ribbon yeah yeah yeah
it's it's interesting because there are
definitely
factions within technology or
technological groups that are
are kind of fighting against that
there's oh say
yeah um yeah i guess um
oh shoot
i i i forget the gentleman's name um but
there there have been some several
people who have been like okay like
the data that you own is um your
property and that
um that if if companies instead of just
getting it for free
uh actually to pay for it then there
would at least be some sort of
monetary exchange for like the things
that we're giving up
in exchange um you know like a couple
years ago was all the rage called data's
the new oil
right but to a certain extent especially
for those uh companies like google and
facebook and others that were
early into the data gathering and
aggregation
it did allow them to have this first
mover
uh advantage that allowed them to
significantly corner the market on these
things before there were any
like laws or outside structures
that allowed for a actual
exchange to happen and
it's kind of like these things that
people didn't know that they had this
thing that they were giving up
and so the argument that like oh well
that was
you know the tacit agreement that you
give up
every time that you use any of these
things
um i feel like we're run into that on
i guess we talked about it earlier the
asymmetric knowledge problem
people had no idea what they were giving
up yeah when they're
actually doing this and without full
understanding of the situation
they couldn't make an informed choice
you know some of the truth is that
they'll make the correct choice but at
least they would have the full
information in in europe we see a
different attitude towards this
right with the right to be forgotten on
google and
um you know laws about what you have to
disclose in terms of your data gathering
uh for for any sort of websites but it's
but it also seems sort of like
um and it maybe shouldn't seem like this
like the david versus goliath thing you
know
or almost like whack-a-mole if we want
to use another thing
um the european governments that do that
are better about
educating their citizens about rights
they ought to have
and things like that that ought to be
respected they're always like you know
five steps behind these big
tech companies um so yeah that may be a
topic that we have to come back to
in another um another
uh session right the big check i think
we should yeah well i think we should
really
circle back to our main topic here truth
yeah how even within a
you know it is important because of the
technology that we have that certain
things become much more difficult
to understand or to to uh
assess as true or false yeah right
yeah so so truth um this is something we
talked about a lot in the last uh
several sessions um we talked about
different theories of truth and how to
understand it
and you know truth is not
just a purely theoretical or speculative
matter
or something to idealize it's something
that we really do
need almost like we need air you know or
shelter or sustenance living without
truth is
or living in a you could say a
communicative domain in which you can
never be
sure what's true or what's false that's
really tough on people
and so um you know there are different
ways
in which we try to get at it there's
some areas in philosophy
you know epistemology uh the word for
for uh epistemology episteme is
it means knowledge but the domain is
also very concerned with what makes
things true how do we know that things
are true
logic you know the main reason we do
logic is to be able to tell
the true apart from the false and to be
able to determine whether arguments
lead us to truth or lead us away from
from truth and there's there's other
you know there's other domains or
disciplines like dialectic or rhetoric
communication all of these have to do
with
shaping or leading us to discovering
communicating
even how to contest uh truth and so
this brings us to you know we said the
topic here is going to be the
marketplace of ideas this is a
very very popular image that
people throw around and you know we
should think first
what is an actual marketplace is is it
the agara
in ancient greece where people would go
and buy and sell
a lot of us don't really go to the agra
to do our shopping these days we
go to particular stores or i don't know
if you if you're like me
you tend to buy things more online and
have other people shop for you and put
it into
nice packages and send it off to you
right
and and so you know there's there's a
lot of different kinds of marketplaces
we could think about everything from
very structured
places where you never get to haggle and
everybody's got their
particular place to the bazaar
where you know you're expected to
bargain with people and you may
talk about asymmetric knowledge problems
right you might not know what's in the
booth next
next door to you where the better
bargain might be
and why so it's clearly not that kind of
marketplace that we're talking about
what what kind of marketplace is the
marketplace of ideas supposed to
be it seems more like the
metaphor is of the marketplace of
classical economics you know
adam smith saying that you know if you
charge too much
or you provide bad service or you don't
you know stand by your product or you
cheat people
you're going to be driven out of the
market and if you provide
people good quality for what they're
willing to pay you satisfy their desires
and ways that they can
go along with well then you're going to
prosper and you're
will have more and more of your kind of
thing there's competition between
different purveyors different suppliers
everybody's looking to fine-tune stuff
so if we think about
truth in that way what kind of
marketplace
do we get we we get a place in which
people are bringing their wares the
things that they
believe the things that they want to say
the things that they
value they're putting them on the table
and they're seeing if other people will
pick them up and if other people do pick
them up
well then there's kind of a transaction
that takes place but it's also a
replication if
if i manage to convince dan of something
that
he doesn't believe right now uh he'll go
around and tell other people about that
thing
right maybe everyone should wear an
anti-leviathan
t-shirt um you know dan doesn't believe
that right now because
he's not wearing one but maybe i
convince him by the end of this and then
he becomes
an anti-leviathan t-shirt evangelist
um that's that you know the truth
down to hobbs yeah well the the truth
becomes
something if we really are thinking in
these terms of marketplaces the truth
then becomes something that's
not just a commodity that you buy and
sell it's something that you
reproduce and the things that are true
should become you know
the norm that's the ideal
right does it work like that
so just like there is this
issue within um economics and
the whole idea of on
uh homo economicus okay which is the the
idealized human
is perfectly rational and when they go
into the market they will
uh try to maximize their um what they
get for
what like money that they get they have
um as they enter into the market
and um but as we know
humans aren't purely rational um we have
a lot of biases
and you see this over and over with
people
you know buying things that are just
totally like from charlotte i remember
like
a couple years ago both the the shake
weight as well as
the thing that you would wear on your ab
that shocked your abs are supposed to
get you
fit without having to do anything all
these things
prey on these ideas of like oh people
want to get fits but they don't actually
want to do the work
or cut down on the eating that would
actually get that would
give them the results um
you know they want to maximize their
output for their input that's
interesting are there equivalents
like that with ideas where people
buy into ideas truths opinions right
um that are too reductive that are
oversimplified that are
crap products and you could say when
they really ought to be
they really ought to be looking for
something that's that's more substantive
that will
improve their life i would say
absolutely
i think there's a lot of them they're
everywhere okay and
i'm i guess i would say that
there's a lot of that in a lot of
religions that they will sometimes
like oh well instead of you know
depending on the religion obviously but
like
instead of like saying i want to
investigate a thing and try to figure
out why it's true or not
you just say like oh well that that is
god
yeah this is what we believe
right yeah and you to take it on faith
yeah and which are things that i i kind
of
i very much oppose i'm very much in like
the skeptical sense of i want to keep on
digging digging but if there's anything
that puts up a wall
and says you shouldn't be looking into
this any further
that that makes me feel very
uncomfortable and i
i feel like those are are often ideas
that prevent us from actually
arriving at truths yeah uncomfortable
in the sense of like you you feel like
there's something
underhanded something hinky going on
uncomfortable in the sense of like i
don't like that that there you're doing
the wrong thing by
saying let's say what what mode of
uncomfortability are we talking
about
specifically like you know one's beliefs
usually leads to one's actions okay
someone believes something
is good on for
someone told you or you have to take
this on faith um
it can thus result in really negative
things and i guess this is
you know we're going to talk about her a
little bit later but like
uh han arnett and the banality of evil
and whole
like oh he's just doing his job like
he's told like well he wants to improve
his numbers
and so he's going to make sure that his
spreadsheet works out well in the end
but doesn't actually take into the
account of what are the actual
consequences to other people
of getting your numbers up like that and
once you remove yourself what's the
spreadsheet
actually measuring if we're talking
about an eichmann yeah that's that's
a great point um i was kind of thinking
in terms of like you know there there's
a lot
of people and we'll expand this so
there's a lot of people in in religious
communities there's a lot of people
in political communities um there's a
lot of people
selling things economically i would even
say there's a lot of people in
education itself who are trying to
pervade to us half truths at best you
know sort of like
things that that contain some true
aspects but
are clearly oversimplifications of and
this used to drive me
nuts because i'm the kind of person like
if i if i'm listening to somebody talk
about
you know what happened historically i
want the i want what i think to be the
real story right which
oftentimes i'm wrong about that it's way
more complicated
than that but but i know that the thing
that they're telling me is bs
you know it's it's been um
sanitized yeah sanitized or it's just
been whittled away until it becomes
something
nice and easy to convey in a few
sentences you know like something you
can have on a plaque
um and and you know it's interesting
because
um as somebody who you know works in
philosophy but also works in religious
studies and
has you know read write quite a few
things
i will encounter to go back to religion
i will encounter
religious people who try to tell me what
the tenets of their faith are and i'm
like i think
in my mind well i know that's wrong
you know this person claims to be an ex
but an ex
actually according to their own
doctrines you know
thinks this or this is the history or
stuff like that
and so when when they tell me things
that are
oversimplified or or sometimes even just
false
um for me that that does
sort of set alarm bells off and i'm like
why is this person what are they trying
to get out of
um telling me something that that isn't
true i'll give you an example in
something that has to do with philosophy
and religion so
there never was within the the catholic
church
any official philosophy or philosopher
you will get a lot of people both um
anti-religious and sort of benighted
catholics telling you
thomas aquinas philosophy is the
official catholic philosophy
it's never been the case and we know
this because
some papal encyclicals actually say that
there is no
official catholic philosophy including
the most recent
you know one by john paul the second
fide say rozzie all right
so you run into people and they're
telling you this line
and you're like well i know that's not
right i may not actually know what the
truth is
i know that this person doesn't have the
truth and i
and i do have i can say this is a true
statement that that person's lying to me
or that person's um deceived or that
person is
um mistaken right so
you don't you don't fully have the truth
at your disposal
but they're very confident usually when
they say these sorts of things and and
it can be about
products you know oh you know if you buy
a subaru now
you'll have it 20 years you know and
you'll be able to send it down to your
kids which is what those subaru
commercials are all about and i'm a
subaru owner
you know so i i think subarus are a good
you know
a good car to have but you look at those
commercials
and you're like this is mostly like lies
you know right so
uh so i'd like to bring this back to the
market the market
is exactly um that you know within the
marketplace there are
lots of different strategies to get
people to buy things
and so all is if you're looking at a
purely
like one-to-one argument of like trying
to make this a marketplace
okay then are we as these
biased individuals that like fall into
you know the bandwagon effect or like
self-serving biases all the time
yeah um and it's really hard for you to
not
like for example uh danny kahneman who
wrote uh
thinking fast and slow it's all about
human biases
says like yeah i spent most my life
doing these biases
i still fall into them yeah because just
knowing them doesn't automatically
inoculate you to these bad
ways of thinking and
that results in us
if we're just gonna go oh well you know
the the cream will rise to the top if
everyone throws out things uh
i would say like the cream doesn't
always rise to the top in in markets as
well there there are so many times where
where things go out and and
are self-replicating um especially as
ideas
yeah um and and especially if you've got
an idea
um take an ideology that has a part of
it that you can't question the ideology
that is on built-in defense mechanisms
for you to try to not actually
investigate that particular ideology
that would be particularly uh
problematic in a marketplace right
because you would have
it's sort of like a product
that is being sold and then
well we have products like this you're
not allowed to repair it yourself
or to look at it's inner workings
yeah yeah that's interesting you know
um what happens when you do that you
void the warranty which is a contract
that says that
if something's wrong with our product
you know god forbid something should not
work right
um even though they know that's going to
happen statistically a certain number of
times
we will we will make it good we will
like you know after we've made you jump
through a bunch of hoops
we will um supply you a new product or
something like that
uh right yeah that you know
if you think about a lot of the products
that we have these days
you know it used to be that you could
work on your car and you can still work
on your car autozone exists right and
you can go and buy
diagnostic computers to let you do the
things that are
connected with that but there's not an
awful lot you can easily do
with the tools that you would have
needed 30 years ago
to work on a car you know i i remember
having the experience
at one point in time i was just going to
change some brake pads
this was this was back in the 1990s and
i had you know a pontiac
6000 i think a you know car that's
long since never not not been made and i
had it jacked up i was out on the street
and i had i
bought the brake pads and i go to look
at things and it required tools that i
didn't have
tools that you wouldn't a lot of people
now do have those star wrenches that's
what it needed
yeah torx yeah yeah that was not common
at the time
and it was one of those sort of like in
your face examples of you cannot mess
with the product go take it to somebody
who can and so i think the you know you
can't question the ideology or you you
can only
go so far with it is sort of like that
in a mechanical
uh way right or um
ideologies in which if you stray from
the ideology
then uh oh repercussions are taken
against you
think of um certain religions that will
like
uh extra what uh disfellowship and
or yeah um
you because you you did something that
was
outside or you start questioning the
teachings that are given there and so
now you're not
like truth isn't the barometer that your
barometer
is um am i going to be able to maintain
the relationships with my friends and my
family do i need to
um what do i need to do in order to
maintain those and we're
like a social species and so it's that's
a very strong motivator for us to
not question certain things if the
consequences of them are so dire
that's actually a great segue into
something i was
wanting us to kick around so in a
marketplace
ideally and these never exist right
all the transactions can be carried out
basically at the same time for the same
cost there's no like hidden things
attached to it
but that's not the way that real
marketplaces
work and so in terms of a marketplace of
ideas
like what you're saying is there there
are some cases where if you even
suggest an idea you're going to pay a
cost for that
it's not it's not so simple as well you
know because jon stewart mills said we
should all be able to express our
opinions
we all get to express our opinions if
you do express certain opinions you will
be
ostracized or people will start looking
at you or it'll be more difficult to get
people to take you seriously the next
time around
and there's there's a lot of cases where
to get access
to uh what is true or even just you know
the information we would need to
be better informed about what's what's
true and what's false we have to pay a
lot
or it may not be available to us at all
maybe somebody came in and
cornered that market you know
right
oh please what was your question i was
going to say so what are some of these
transaction
costs that are unfair what would be
examples of that within
the marketplace of ideas hopefully
leading to truth but but perhaps
not leading to that you know why why do
we
why do we settle for shoddy products
rather than
the high-end stuff you know
well yes you know part of it is that
we're
we're all born into families and
families usually have certain ideas
um and we are given this like basket of
goods automatically
that are our base ideas right yeah and
um you know to take uh what is that
uh either sunk cost fallacy it's like oh
well
i've been i've been believing these
things all my time i'm all life
i'm like these are now a part of me
these are some things that i i
can even like base my whole personality
or
my whole world view upon yeah and any
point in time that i
might swap out one of these
um things i need to have to have a
reconciliation
with all of what those
the consequences of me swapping out this
idea if this is a really foundational
idea
so i don't know um maybe uh
the question of like free will yes or no
like if i'm going to change my position
on that
that that has all potentially a lot of
consequences
for how i'm going to act in my own life
as well as
the uh things that i would expect from
other people exactly
yeah the judgments i would make about
them yeah and you know i'm thinking
about like people
who they hold on to ideas
almost like hoarders hold on to
um physical objects as goods
because they're connected with you know
somebody who's gone
somebody who's not even in the picture i
i can't change this
point of view because that's my
connection to
my grandma you know or
some some other strongly developed
relationship
it could be a teacher could be a coach
could be who knows
i think there's there's a lot of people
who suffer
in in that kind of situation
yeah uh
and so we have to then ask like what
what is the reason that we should
believe things versus and this is kind
of like what we talked about the last
couple weeks and like what are the
basicies for truth yeah
um and i would say that that
you know it's nice that you want to have
this connection
but it's not a basis by which truth can
be
derived yeah that's quite
that's very good and then you know if
you have kids of your own or
i don't know if like if you're in
education right you have your pupils
your students are kind of like your kids
in a way
because you're transmitting something to
them if you're
stuck in a wrong-headed unjustified way
of
looking at the world or at least certain
topics
you're going to inevitably inevitably
pass that on to them
you know and so that you could say maybe
there's a duty to
extricate oneself from from those things
coming back to the
to the market though i mean can we can
we frame that in terms of
market failures uh you know we have
inefficient
markets um
we have perverse markets like
like what we had like think of um some
of these ideas
or ideologies that like kind of suck you
in and stick you
and think of like a um a company town
where you have to buy from the company
store
yeah and i feel like that's a good
analogy between
like oh well it's a it's supposedly a
market but one person controls it and if
you don't do
that um your entire livelihood is
um at risk yeah and maybe maybe that of
the survival of your family as well the
other thing you hold dear
it's interesting too because in those
company towns those are set up in such a
way that you
never you never get ahead you never get
out of debt you're buying company
products you're paying
you know rent for the house that you're
living in and you never make enough to
actually
get anywhere is there an equivalent like
that
in terms of truth and knowledge
maybe the labor that you're doing is
replicating the
ideology right and you can never get
yourself to the point where you wouldn't
have to do that anymore right you could
successfully move to another place and
have your own
your own domain or you would retire and
you know not have to spout the company
line anymore yeah i think we could say
that there are a lot of cases like that
yeah i can definitely the easiest go-to
are like certain cults in which
like uh everything is for the greater
good of this
of either the prophet or the you know
the leader
and we're all going to have some you
know incredible
uh reward that we have in some sort of
afterlife
um and to uh to totally discard
everything that we have here in the
the physical world in order to
try to make sure that we are good with
that
eventual uh reward
and yeah yeah so i mean cults
are you i think you're right are a good
example of that
totalitarian societies as hana
rent pointed out have a similar dynamic
in the
erosion of like the what we can call the
the value of truth or the distinction
between
truth and falsity or um
facts and and fiction and
i wonder if we can say that something
like that occurs
in seemingly more free
environments where a person is still
in large part deprived of truth so if
you think about
consumerism and you know the notion that
you're you're made happy by basically
making a lot of money and buying the
best stuff and
you know consuming it enjoying it all of
that
you know when people live that sort of
lifestyle they're often not
happy except at particular moments they
bought the new product they spent some
money you know they did what they call
retail therapy
and they're happy for for a short space
and then they're not happy because
that's that's not really where you're
going to find any sort of lasting
happiness so then you can say well why
the hell are they doing it
what's are they masochists you know do
they just want to be unhappy
or you know where are they what is
holding them in place and they say well
you know tons and tons of you know
marketing and
advertisement and everybody else around
them behaving
in the same way right um it's not a
totalitarian society it's actually got a
lot of freedom i mean you can get as
many different kinds of spaghetti sauce
as you want going you know going to pick
and save
or metro mart right i don't know if
you've ever walked down
the one in in sherwood there's like an
entire aisle
almost for spaghetti sauce right and i
feel like i got vertigo the last time
you got a spaghetti sauce yeah now
if your life revolves around
the prestige spaghetti sauce or getting
the best bargain or
pick whatever other consumerist value
um i think that you not only are you
buying into some things that are that
are false in place of things that are
true about say human nature some
philosophical
or psychological opinions or judgments
but it's going to lead you inevitably to
mistaking truth for falsity and other
other ways right um the way in which you
approach other people
the the way in which you decide what
matters for yourself
um and that's just one example i think
we could have other examples where a
person is not in a cult or a
totalitarian society
but the distinction between truth and
falsity is kind of getting
eroded i think the political arena
is becoming especially on social
media becoming like that in in our our
present day you know
when the main motivation for a lot of
people seems to be to own the own the
libs or own the conservatives
um that's not truth conducive right
no that's
cutting off one's nose despite one's
face
uh you know like we are
still a polis together at least as
you know the united states and where
yeah we're kind of stuck together
creating
yeah and if we're we're creating a
narrative in which
you know a large portion of the
population is your
enemy um then it's only going to
tear us down to the i guess the
betterment of
another country that might want to
create and so discord you know along
with that though in terms of truth is
so the other the other people become the
enemy for
however they're construed right what can
you count on an enemy to do
to lie to you to um to
deliberately um downplay whatever's true
about them and
you know put out other things that are
untrue and try
to try to infect you with untruth as
well
and especially you know not just you but
your community your kids your
workplace whatever it would happen to
to be um and that's that's a very
you know uh strong stance against
not just the other person as being a bad
person but as being
corrosive of truthfulness
yeah but i wanted to
so going to the the marketplace again
like
there's this whole idea of kind of like
the cream is going to rise to the top
but this is really
you know the the ad popular policy
whatever happens to be popular
is is the good thing within the market
yeah yeah um but that is not a
valid reasoning stance for actually
coming
to the truth um with that said i
i do like yes this idealized idea of
what like
the market should be um does have at
least
one thing that i'll benefit this uh
analogy
that's the marketplace of ideas of the
the free flow
of information yeah that the people
can present ideas um
to to the masses in order for them to
kind of
mull them over i guess the problem this
is i guess
that a lot of people don't have
the full skills to
objectively try to
inquire into the truth of these ideas
uh and and there's you know advertising
and rhetoric
all around to try to work on people's
natural proclivities to
these biases that we have to get them to
believe things
um for bad reasons yeah and
and so i think like in this idealized
thing of hey
we're we're like you're going to the
forum and you're going to make a speech
and everyone's got like a background in
in rhetoric so they know when
when people are trying to swindle them
by by uh making arguments towards like
emotion or to to biases
yeah this this sounds like a really
great
you know way of doing things and and
maybe this
i guess this kind of comes off a little
bit elitist but like
not everyone has the time or
the uh the opportunity to
be fully informed of how to work through
our syllogism
um or to to work through what our
fallacious arguments are not
and if you you just throw things out
there and get people to agree with them
for bad reasons that the outcome of this
marketplace
isn't truth it's just you know add
popular move act
yeah that's i think that that's uh
that's often what does happen um i think
we can also talk about there being
some you know the marketplace sounds
like it's you know each
each person has the same capacity to get
other people to listen to them and we
know that's not
not the case you know corporations have
way
way more money than well than most
individual people
there are some super rich people who
also have that but
let's say corporations and super rich
people have
way more money that can amplify their
message and
drown out the messages of other people
that that they don't want to be
heard than all the rest of us right
and so you know is it really a
fair marketplace of ideas if you've got
one guy with a giant megaphone
and another guy who has to like talk
through i don't know he's got to like
talk through like a
thing that de-intensifies the signal
it strikes me as as clearly uh
unfair and and you know biased towards
those who are going to use that to
improve their position within the
marketplace of ideas
and we can talk about other kinds of
prestige like if you're a harvard
professor
as opposed to somebody at uwm you've got
a bigger mouthpiece as well just by
virtue of that name
even though you might be a complete
dummy that just happened to get in
and the uwm professor might be brilliant
you know sometimes these things do even
out it's not to say that like
money or social status dominates
everything but i do think we have to
take account of that
in talking about this marketplace
it's clearly not a
fairly set up marketplace the way that
that its proponents
talk the way that they present it you
know
this reminds me of um an out of context
situation which
is coined by um ian
banks uh in the culture series talking
about
um an out of context situation is is
what happens when you've got a a
really nice thriving island nation and
all of a sudden
there's these nice uh white sails that
show up on the horizon
and some guys come out with these uh
these sticks
that they can point at you and they they
kill you dead
and and so there's there's no context
in the current technological advancement
of this particular tribe
yeah to what the hell is going on here
and um and so
i make this analogy to the the
difference between like
uh even us or just you know some guy on
the street that's
going to want to enter into this you
know
marketplace for our ideas as as this
this guy basically as
the the the nice islander
um and and a corporation that's got like
an advertising firm and psychologists
and and uh armies of people that are all
trying to in coordination on using
a lot greater technology and reach
in order to totally bowl over this other
person it doesn't matter if one person
is right or not
just that the sheer force that is
brought
to bear is overwhelming yeah i think
that's that
that is a good analogy um and they may
even
like suck in that person and and
uh subvert their message so it becomes
part of their greater message
um and and it's unfortunate you know a
lot of people say oh i'm not gonna be
moved by advertising
money doesn't really do that much but we
know that it does
you know looking at how elections go or
looking at how
advertising campaigns for you know
consumer good products work
as a matter of fact a significant
portion of non-generic
foodstuffs is the packaging and the the
advertisement that's that's part of what
separates your
you know brand name from your generic
stuff which is often the same
product say made in the same factory
at the same day it just changed out the
packaging yeah
so um
really you know the very beginning i
said i was a little bit pessimistic
actually not a little bit pretty
pessimistic about
our contemporary situation um
you know i think there's some factors
that that go into that that we could
talk about that
make our era a bit more difficult than
previous ones and you know one of them
is
is the 24-hour news cycle which we now
take for
granted i mean you talk just a little
bit earlier you talked about the free
flow of information which we do see as a
good thing
right especially now that we have the
internet and there's so many places that
you can go
and there's even great sites that like
you know
keep people from being able to like take
down stuff like the way back machine
so that people can't just um obliterate
the
the truth of the bad stuff that they
wrote right we can
actually get public record to that but
we are
really inundated with um
you know maybe there's too much
information and it and it's constantly
coming
at us how are how are we able to discern
what's
true and what's false when we're like
you know by the time that we figure out
that this thing is true there's five
more it's sort of like having an inbox
right
we used to have physical inboxes and as
you finish
one report on something and you put it
in your out box
five more have been placed in your inbox
and you're like all right i'll get on
the next one
and you pull that one out and by the
time you get done with that one five
more are stacked up and now you got nine
in your inbox
sometimes it feels like that um
in terms of trying to stay on top of
everything and then there's the opposite
thing where people realize they can't
stay on top of it and they feel like
well how
how would i know what's true or false
given that
i'm not you know cognizant of half the
well not even half
i'm i'm not even cognizant of a sliver
of what's going on
around me how can i know what's true i
mean what what's your
do you have a feeling like that or um
but i don't i guess i don't have a
a problem i guess my foundation a lot of
times
is looking at a lot of peer-reviewed
studies okay so this is the thing i've
gotten
that seems time consuming though too it
is it is
to actually dig into these things so
like i know that like to a certain
extent i'm
i'm i'm missing things because sometimes
i'll be reading things that are totally
outside of
my area of expertise um but at least i
know that there is
some checks and balances in these things
of being something that is peer-reviewed
and so it has greater clout than just
some guy
who's out there putting up a website
yeah i can put up a website in an hour
and put up whatever the heck i want
um just because there's a website out
there doesn't mean that's true it's like
i think this is one of those
things that we we used to have the
ability to just go oh
something is printed it takes a lot of
time and money
and there's a barrier to entry to
actually put these things in print
so it was a you know a shorthand a
heuristic
by uh uh you know a cognitive bias to
say oh well
it's print imprint and therefore it's
it's more likely to be true than not
which you know with the whole idea of
like yellow journalism in the
early 1900s probably throws it out but
people were like
at least there was less
chance you get total crackpot ideas yeah
yeah you might have like politically
motivated ideas but it wasn't usually
totally out the deep end
yeah um but nowadays the the barrier
entry is so
low that anyone can go out and put up
with whatever you want and thus you can
have anyone
on you know one of the under our on
the self-serving biases or the uh
confirmation bias that we we go out and
we look for the things
that confirm our hypothesis and we
discount anything that says
otherwise and because there is such a
low
barrier to entry anything is out there
you can find something to support your
idea
whatever and so you you see this with
the the like the rise in
the flat earthers which used to be you
know
yeah it used to be really hard to find
one of these guys now
you've given them a a forum where they
can all gather and
all reference their own stuff and
they've created this little community
for each other
you know this reminds me of something
that i
i put in front of a few of my colleagues
um
years and years ago when the internet
was becoming a you know big thing in the
early
uh 2000s um and i was i was thinking how
it eroded
what would we call it um you know
we'll call it violations of social norms
so like if you were into something
really niche and kind of
inconsequential like you know collecting
beanie babies or something like that
which actually isn't
tricky actually not that that niche
because people were like
using them as a form of currency but but
it was kind of a minority thing
okay the internet probably made it
easier for you to connect with people
you could go on you know buy
on ebay you know this this one or that
one or you could like go and find out
what the catalog was and all that so
that's cool
right it created a kind of community
if you were into something that was
really skeevy
um you generally before the internet
unless you had like a peer group that
was equally skeevy you kept it to
yourself
because people would be like you're a
creep get out of here
but once the internet you know
exploded with chat rooms and
forums and all these sorts of things
well you could you could be the one
person in your town who was into
something really
sketchy and then you could find 50 other
people within
hours who are like oh no man it's not
you it's society it's all those squares
and
you're you know you're one of us and
we're a community
and you know this is just as as good as
anybody else
and then that would reinforce you and
then and then you know it would things
would come out and now i kind of think
there's probably a lot of things that
were
at that time considered um violations of
social norms in the united states that
have
you know um been eroded that way
that it turned out to be a good thing
like you know drug legalization there's
there's some drugs that we probably
should legalize there's plenty that we
we should keep under you know very close
surveillance still i think
uh that are quite bad for people and it
allowed people to communicate back and
forth outside high times
that's probably good right but there's a
lot of things where
the baser tendencies of people have been
fostered and
encouraged and you know
i know one of the things we're going to
talk about is echo chambers and
i think the inner it's not as if echo
chambers didn't exist before the
internet
but they certainly proliferated in in
that and that has a deleterious effect
on
on truth because once you're in one of
these chambers you mentioned all these
different kinds of biases
they're they're rife with that right and
those are going to stand in the way not
only of attaining truth but even
seeing that you're not attaining truth
and that
what you've got isn't the truth you know
so like i think the idea i wanted to
bounce off
do you think the internet did that do
you think that that
or or should we say well it's not the
internet that did that human nature was
like that before the internet
um it's just a little bit worse now it
enabled it
yeah okay uh unfortunately
um it also enables like some of the
the worst things so i was thinking about
like what you're saying like
there's a guy that's got some skeevy
ideas
um yes
uh and you've got like two sets of
skeevy ideas okay
one set of skeevy ideas that make you
money and so like
like maybe we're gonna be trafficking
drugs or whatnot which is
a skeevy idea but also it's very
profitable and so you get enough people
that are
are wanting to make that so you can you
can create those organizations
so you've got like criminal
organizations which you know polar
paraded before the internet as well yeah
but you and then you had
skeevy ideas that were just like
really really negative and so for
example like like the worst thing
that that immediately pops into your
mind is like child pornography
yeah and how those on because
of both the gathering ability and
the early pseudo-anonymity that the
internet
provides it allows people that would be
you know
totally unable to ever even approach
this topic
um because they would have been like
totally
you know ostracized from their community
for even bringing
up to find those few other people that
also have that same proclivity and
concern you're the normal one
yeah yeah yeah
that's that's that's an interesting
example um i was thinking more in terms
of like
you know viewing again going back to
politics viewing the
other side is like these these horrible
enemies who are just
absolutely trying to erode everything
that the country stands for
and we need to like be willing to use
force against them now i think there's
been it's not as if we didn't have that
we had a civil war before you know and
we had lots and lots of
conflict before but i think the internet
um
exacerbates that yeah i see people
like calling like just large portions of
our country
like evil and i really have a problem
with that because
it's like are we are we not at least to
a certain extent connected to each other
if we just deem people evil how is that
actually
bringing us to a point where we can have
some sort of reconciliation
so potentially so when we have stuff
like that going on can we actually talk
about a marketplace
of ideas like in in politics or is that
is that metaphor just no longer really
once you see someone as the enemy
like the the free flow of information
dies because the first thing
what is it the first thing to go and war
is truth
that's right so that's that's a good
pithy statement
and we probably need to go out on
another good pithy statement
about truth as well so
we leave you today the words of hannah
arnett
when we talk about lying let us remember
that the lie did not creep into politics
by some
accident of human sinfulness
oral outrage for this reasonable low is
not
likely to make it disappear
[Music]
so
[Music]
you